henry kissinger now says that ukraine  should just cede some territory to  russia which happens to be the exact  same opinion of noam chomsky this is  number one really kind of weird it  wouldn't be you wouldn't imagine that  henry kissinger from the right and noam  chomsky from the left would end up with  the same perspective on anything but  it's also a reminder how in 2022  there are some really strange i wouldn't  call it horseshoe theory where you go so  far left or right that you end up on the  other side but there are just some  really strange political factions being  staked out and that's exactly what we're  seeing here are you surprised to see  kissinger and chomsky on the same page  on this issue let me know in the  comments and remember full coverage on  my youtube channel